-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show." You're here.
You made it.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching.
I am very excited about this.
One of the biggest stars
in the world, Dwayne Johnson,
is on the show, tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love when Dwayne is here
because there's always a chance
that he pulls Kevin Hart
out of his pocket.
It's just -- It's exciting.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Dwayne will be out here
in a little bit,
or sooner if he wants.
I mean, who's going to stop him?
You know, he can do
whatever he wants.
Let's get to some news first,
guys.
Last night on CNN,
President Biden sat down
for a prime-time interview with
Jake Tapper.
At one point, Tapper asked
the President whether his age is
a concern, and Biden said,
"Not at all, Wolf."
[ Laughter ]
I think Biden is sick of this
question because he responded,
"I'm so old, I remember
when people watched CNN."
[ Laughter ]
I got a feeling they're not
going to stop questioning
Biden's sharpness until he says,
"Person, woman,
man, camera, TV."
[ Laughter ]
When they got to the topic of
Russia, Biden said that
Vladimir Putin totally
miscalculated
by invading Ukraine.
And I believe him because
if there's one thing
Biden's an expert on,
it's miscalculating.
-Let me start off
with two words.
Made in America.
[ Laughter ]
-Close enough. Who cares?
Two words.
[ Applause ]
Biden also said he has no
intention of meeting with Putin
at next month's G20 summit.
Meanwhile, Trump and Putin are
planning a couple's
Halloween costume.
"No, Donald, I'm the avocado.
You're the toast."
[ Laughter ]
Tapper also asked Biden about
the economy
and where it's headed.
Take a look at this.
-Should the American people
prepare for a recession?
-No. Look, they've been saying
this now how --
every six months they say this.
There's no guarantee that
there's gonna be a rec--
I don't think there will be
a recession.
If it is, it will be
a very slight recession.
[ Laughter ]
-A slight recession? Yeah.
I wouldn't invite someone
to a party
if you told me
they had a smidge of COVID.
Do you know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
Just a little bit.
Some big entertainment news,
guys.
Our good friend Blake Shelton,
just announced that
after next season
he's leaving "The Voice."
[ Audience aws ]
Yep, Blake is stepping away from
his chair so he can go home
and spend more time
in his chair.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, guys, there's a lot
going on in the news right now,
but instead of me just telling
you about it,
I thought it would be nice to
give you the chance
to decide what we talk about.
That's right, it's time for
"You Pick the Joke."
Here we go.
-♪ Joke ♪
♪ You pick the joke ♪
-So, here's how it works.
I'm going to show you two news
stories, then you guys get to
pick which one we talk about.
Here we go. Let's take a look at
story number one.
-Gas prices are on the rise
in the U.S.
and could soon hit the national
average of $4 a gallon.
-Mm. Here's story number two.
-A bizarre story out of
Westmoreland County tonight.
-Police say a man took off all
his clothes and started eating
vegetables out of people's
backyard gardens.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright.
Which story do you want to talk
about, one or two?
-Two!
-Two.
Okay, alright. Good choice.
That's right.
-Oh, my God.
-A naked guy was in people's
gardens eating their vegetables.
Homeowners were like,
"Honey, is that a string bean
in the cucumber patch?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's nuts.
-Let's try another story
up here. It's up to you.
Here's story number one.
-The Nobel Prize in economic
sciences was awarded
to three U.S.-based economists.
-Alright.
Here's story number two.
-There is new video of a failed
robbery attempt
at a fast-food restaurant.
According to Houston police,
the suspect told the employees
this was his first robbery.
He had a change of heart,
and then he leaves empty-handed.
-Yeah.
Want to talk about one or two?
-Two!
-Great choice. That's right.
First-time robber changed
his mind about the robbery.
He was like, "Give me all
your money, or not!
Either way, I just hope we can
be friends."
[ Laughter ]
"I just want to be friends.
It's just --
We have a lot in common."
[ Applause ]
Alright.
Let's do one last batch.
It's your choice.
Here's story number one.
-There is a renewed possibility
of a rail strike
after the country's third
largest railroad union
rejected a labor deal.
-And here's story number two.
-A nursing home in Taiwan is
apologizing after hiring
a stripper to perform
for senior citizens.
-Want to talk about one or talk
about story number two?
-Two!
-Alright, perfect.
That's a great choice.
That's right.
They brought in strippers
to a nursing home.
The seniors loved it.
It was the first time anyone
made it rain with
nickels and pennies.
There you go.
That was "You Pick the Joke."
We have a great show.